he enjoys you to trigonometric functions
now that we can differentiate these
things you can integrate them okay
they're just kind of two sides of the
same coin there are four main categories
of problems that we deal with one two
three oh and you've actually encountered
all of them just not with trig functions
before okay so where we begin the most
simplest client is to take those
derivative statements and just turn them
around and through minute of this you do
this
so therefore in turn all of that will
send you back and you add a custom
integration so that's just an indefinite
integral right can you guess what the
next problem will be once you've
mastered indefinite integrals definite
eros right now we look at them just as
numbers just like evaluate this integral
from here to here but of course the main
application of definite integrals are in
measuring two kinds of things number one
areas and - well because it's volumes
very good okay a definite definite now
where it expands from there just like it
did with polynomials and Exponential's
is for both of these categories of
problems whatever what happens when
there's sort of a combination of
functions when you have something that
requires recognition of you chain rule
and the reversal of that okay so if
you've got some F - sign of FS how do
you integrate that okay I've just like
we did with chain rule and exponential
so it's been a while in it the last
thing and this one maybe you wouldn't
guess the last thing like all of these
recovered under every other kind of
function we've learned how to integrate
the next one though is less common
substitution actually comes later we're
just going to think about combining the
identities that you currently know which
I mainly the Pythagorean identity and
the double angle and like compound angle
identities combining these with these
right often the integrand that you get
handed to integrate you'd be like I
don't know how to integrate this I don't
have any standard form but if you
manipulate it you've some identities you
can take a trig function that kind of
looks weird and turn
into something that you can deal with
with your normal methods okay
so one two three four that's what we're
going to very quickly march through and
I think based on the fact that you've
done some different training through
frictions it won't be that complicated
so let's begin the simple ones let's
call this so let's just quickly rehearse
we actually have already said this so
hopefully this will just be my vision
let's rehearse what are the three
derivative statements good morning but
let's state them as integral statements
okay what was the first thing we learned
how to differentiate so okay so when we
differentiate the side we ended up with
plus so therefore the integral of cos is
going to give youth besides that's where
it came from in the same way the next
one that we worked out was cause when we
differentiate that we got negative sign
right now therefore if what I'm
interested in is this as we've seen
before when we limped to integration the
first time and you're like what in which
what am i doing am i differentially
integrating and it is quite busy and
here you get additional things to kind
of keep in your head because of which
one becomes a plus which one becomes a
minus etc for me I find myself I mean
this step that I'm about to write down
you were probably not right for
something as simple as this but later on
will be very helpful to you I try and
take advantage of the fact that excuse
me I know the derivatives really well so
I'm going to take that and use that I'm
going to write this and make it as clear
as possible what the derivative was that
I was expecting so remember you just
told me that derivative causes negative
sign so negative side is what I'm
looking for
okay so this is not negative sign so I
am going to make it maybe you sign you
see what I've done there right this is
the kind of thing you did when you were
using reverse chain rule for polynomials
okay when I differentiate this right
what are you expecting to get out of
that we need different years there's
going to be a three and then there's
going to be a two and then you get this
right it comes down so therefore if I
asked you to do this you'd say oh that's
not what I've expected right
the power is supposed to go up we're
supposed to have multiplied by that and
there's that inside guy as well so the
way I would write this is to take
advantage of me knowing this I would
write it like this because they aren't
that integrated is exactly the form that
I want right so in the same way here
it's a minus sign that's where I should
have come from it will minimize a little
bit of confusion off like do I add a
minus to do I'm not I think the less you
memorize the best so this of course is
what gives you that yes are you happy
with that
you see hard on it there was one last
basic indefinite integral that we learn
we differentiate a not side or cause we
differentiated Ted and what we got out
of that was wet so therefore the
integral of this is this okay now just
to round that off and we'll add this
right down the bottom it wasn't out of
them like the standard statements but
here it's like oh I have to do do side
and cause there's one missing right what
was the other was missing 10 but we
noticed that it wasn't quite as neat as
this right the integral of 10/10 is in
fact our ratio right it's a racially
between sine and cos it's a ratio
between two ratios it's in the form F -
ah all right
f - ah F except not quiet what's the not
quietly yeah good if I've got sign on
cause the site is not the derivative of
course negative sign is so I need a
minus sign at the front to compensate so
that's what lit lands us here if you
reform
and one of the wonderful things about
this andö encourages its as much as
possible in this stage before you're
really confident with this is always
when you get to here differentiate back
it's not hard to different JPAC right
that's a really good thing because the
practices your ability to get the
derivative and get it accurately and
then you can know yes I got it right yes
the minus sign is there it's not there
all that kind of thing okay all right
any questions on that make sense let's
say I go add an edit definite integral
this time okay so okay now I'm actually
going to do this not mainly to practice
the skill of it but actually to show you
something neat and then we have this we
have the theory function of sine X on
the board already
what isn't it's negative cos x right so
being that it is definite I don't need
to worry about the constant because it's
gonna add and subtract cancel itself out
now I've got two boundaries right so
let's go ahead and evaluate just be
watchful for all of these signs flying
around in fact you might even like to
put that - I got this right because it
is just a constant after all okay when I
evaluate what would you like me to put
on the next line so I'm gonna go ahead
I'm gonna do the promise now like so
okay that's gonna save me some grief
because yeah exactly the mistake you
just made cuz of ply I think you should
always sort of visualize this thing
right and if you need to draw like a
really thumbnail sketch of it on the
side do it right
there's two pi so is pi yeah it's
negative one it's right there in the
middle okay so I'm gonna have negative
one there what's close of zero again
look at the graph it's one so this is
negative negative two this is two so you
can see what what result have I just
shown okay what area does this
correspond to if what I was asking whose
area here is the graph what would the be
the shaded region that corresponds
yes it's just this first region right
this part over here one of the wonderful
things about this is you know how I
introduce these radians I would like
well I apply it's such a gross no but to
do it well the reason why is because
look at the simplicity of that number
right in exactly the same way as when we
introduced either E and E to the X and
so on
it's like aha e to the X it's gradient
at that point there is exactly one not a
little bit off not a little bit more it
is exactly one in exactly the same way
that when you introduce radians and
everything is in terms of pi all the
numbers come out like the exact values
just like with when you first learn the
tree the exact values